was geht hier ist oder max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video wir
spielen heute ist liga.de mit hacks und
zwar habe ich mir so eine kleine
erweiterung installiert die hier einige
kleine ja modifizierung ermöglicht es
ist jetzt kein krasser eingriff ins
spiel
also ich hab nicht einfach so wenn ich
eine taste drücke ist mein wurm direkt
1000 meter lange werdet schon sehen
eigentlich relativ überschaubar hier im
menü sieht man schon so carsten becker
da kann man halt irgendwas lustiges
selbst im hintergrund machen laut
graphics also dass weniger grafik
aufwändig ist skate aid keine ahnung
ja und hier kann man noch von 30 bleibt
youtube es sind kann man clans auswählen
die dann irgendwie oft zäh eingetragen
wurden als leser plus also wie stereo
nur plus heißt das ganze übrigens droht
ich würde sagen wir nennen uns einfach
mal kran ii testen das ganze aus und ich
zeige euch was hier abgeht so als erstes
sieht das mal ganz normal aus ist auf
die wenigen kleinen tricks die ich euch
gerade jetzt gezeigt habe ihr seht auch
schon hier und ein ip wird eingeblendet
damit kann man ganz einfach wenn man mit
anderen leuten zusammen spielen will auf
die ip joinen bis darauf sieht man erst
mal optisch gar nichts anderes ist ist
auch nicht viel mehr was man machen kann
mit dem kleinen heck das andere was was
damit noch möglich ist ganz einfach man
kann raussuchen und dadurch halten
relativ guten überblick kriegen deshalb
ich habe auch schon ein paar leute
gehört die habe das ist doch gar kein
hack ich will aber schon also man kriegt
dadurch schon kleinen spiel vorteil ist
auch sehr gespannt so ob ich dafür
irgendwie zu tode getadelt werde in den
kalten getrommelt lustig wer von euch
stress bekommen dass ich das mache aber
ich würde eigentlich sagen also es
verändert jetzt das spielgeschehen nicht
so allzu groß und hier ist jetzt auch
nichts wie minecraft also da juckt mich
persönlich er gesagt wenig ob leute
sowas installiert haben oder nicht ich
dachte nur ist es lustig und deshalb
wollte ich euch mal zeigen wir werden
einfach probieren jetzt mit diesem hack
ich sag das wort zur und gehörte
irgendwie bisschen schuldig bedeute ich
das sage diese erweiterung dieses
plug-in haben so viele leute installiert
es gibt sogar richtig viele leute die
sich noch einfacher plus nennen also die
quasi werbung dafür machen und ich will
gar nicht wissen wie viele andere das
sowieso drin haben die letzten monate
liegt mir nicht so super mega gut bei
mir einfach weichheit weg mega wenig
videos produziert habe
da ist es ja eigentlich naheliegend dann
habe ich gesehen dass ich mal wieder so
muss einen kleinen ja so einen kleinen
meist auch und fertig war erreicht hatte
so dass ich mal wieder solche okay okay
manchmal muss man aufhören mitreden wenn
es viele leckere kugel hin gibt okay wir
sind schon bei 10.000 das ist bisher
noch wenig zu verschulden dem wecklein
erweitern wieder aber guckt euch mal
einfach so nah ran wie der wurm ist
einfach so gigantisch jetzt das ist
richtig lustig aber man kann auch
dementsprechend weit raus und alles
beobachten also ist schon relativ stark
gerade wenn man groß ist muss man ja mit
relativ viel voraussicht spielen sage
ich mal da kann es natürlich nützlich
sein wenn man ein bisschen weiter gucken
kann was gerade erzählen wollte ich
hatte so festgestellt
also ich hatte das lag sowie der vorfall
auf dem bett irgendwie so zu fall die
demotiviert also ich war voll
demotiviert selbst wenn die youtube
studio etwaigen schaden da hatte ich mal
wieder eine million aufrufe im letzten
monat geknackt was heißt mal wieder ich
hatte das eigentlich immer bis auf die
phase wo ich jetzt so wenig videos
gemacht hat wegen avi und so und dann
war das wieder geknackt nämlich direkt
aufgesprungen und hatte so eine so einen
moment dachte ich okay du machst was
ganz egal was du machst ist was das war
auf jeden fall cool ja und so ist dieses
video entstanden
okay die eingesperrt die guten leute ja
die kriegen wir eingesperrt easy wie
absolvieren was ist da draußen so
unterwegs sieht sehr entspannt aus um
mich herum also ich habe auf jeden fall
keine giganten vor der nase so und hier
schön kleiner machen immer den kreis
drei stück sind da drin
das kann schon schondorf sein erstes
daun
und ich bin down wir nennen uns einfach
mal damit die anderen auch eine chance
nehmen wir uns mal hacker damit ihr auch
verstehen dass wir hacken ne du musst ja
auch fair bleiben also dadurch stehe ich
quasi dass das gleichgewicht dass ich
durch meinen daher durch das
installieren des plugins gefährdet habe
stellt jetzt wieder her bin ich kein
guter mensch
ja wenn ich jetzt mal richtig action
machen dass wir wieder ein bisschen
größer werden und der typ hat auf uns
abgesehen aber gerne nehmen wir mit
oder um es ein richtig großer sowie
teamkollege megathema kann voll
beobachten wo die leute hingehen oder
das ist auch eine art kiosk in irgendwie
dass sie zu hause wird irgendwie richtig
glitzern von eis und ich würde direkt
okay leute jetzt beginnt der aller dazu
versuch krass zu werden
viertes mal dass ich eine rolle spiele
jetzt werde ich so was von reinhauen ich
werde voll konzentriert sein
ihr werdet sehen ich meinen weg zur
spitze kämpfen
hat kann gesehen ich habe jetzt das
ultimative hacker upgrade gemacht ich
habe mir in m lg hintergrund reingepackt
bei dem man absolut gar nichts mehr
erkennen kann und ich habe noch ein paar
andere shortcuts ausgecheckt man kann
jetzt auch im spiel den skin ändern
doch sehr nice wir haben jetzt alle
diese energie kraft sozusagen gesammelt
und es muss uns jetzt wirklich mal ein
anliegen sein dass wir sie sammeln die
bündeln und damit jetzt erster platz
werden
merkel das war auf jeden fall wirklich
unklug dieses den energy hintergrund zu
wählen also wirklich leute alter
säugling ist irgendjemand so diese
regenbogenfarben hatte kempen
wahrscheinlich gar nicht voll ich finde
es voll cool dass man hier wie die farbe
während man spielt ändern kann
es geht immer zurück das geht zurück
nach wie vor muss ich musste erst mal
platz eins energie kraft sammelt ich
weiß dass war dieses mlg glück glaube
ich gerade hier wo ich glaube die mlg
kraft war einfach zu viel ich nehme es
noch mal raus und jetzt seht ihr mich
jeder wenn ich über 10.000 falls nicht
offiziell sogar mit hacks zu schlecht
für dieses spiel sind mittlerweile schon
auf platz fünf jetzt wird es langsam
series mittlerweile ist es echt gold
wert dass man die möglichkeit hat
einfach ein bisschen raus zu suchen und
zu schauen wer wo unterwegs ist mega ist
auf jeden fall das mega intense also die
server sind geradezu sind gerade
brechend voll und man kann sich kaum
bewegen vielleicht liegt es auch daran
dass ich so nah in der mitte bin aber es
passiert echt selten was wo man wirklich
sagen kann okay jetzt gehe ich raus
jetzt wisst ihr ich was es ist mega mega
spannend ich bin mir nach wie vor nicht
ganz sicher ich bin übrigens auf platz
zwei jetzt ich bin mir nach wie vor
nicht ganz sicher ob ich das so als
richtigen heck empfinde bei irgendwie
ist das sowas wie opti fein so man wenn
du bei minecraft kann ob tief ein hast
du nicht raus kommen kannst und nicht
ran zoomen kannst hast du auch und
eigentlich einen deutlichen nachteil so
im pvp
aber irgendwie ist es ja doch nicht so
gravierend also man betitelt ja niemand
der opti fein benutzt als hacker also
zumindest macht das niemand den ich
kenne wir sind platte nummer eins leute
haben es geschafft tatsächlich
unglaublich mit nur 17.000 das ist ein
witz also mit 17.000 auf platz 1 zu
kommen das ist echt besonders also da
braucht man schon eine menge eine menge
glück für bzw
nicht so talentierte mitspieler was
mache ich jetzt hier gerade es ist so
waghalsig okay da ist das ende von
meiner schlange wortes richtig
gefährlich was bringt halt auch nicht
mal was du wirklich beraten riese
explodiert und ich hab' ich habe beide
gekillt beide kleinen und das kann ich
jetzt mega gut als köder benutzen
die geben sich das ja alles schön holen
ich warte dass der rote absicht dieses
ende vom dieser klatsche nicht gerade
gekehrt leute
okay wir haben's geschafft platz eins
was sagt ihr hacks oder nicht in ordnung
oder nicht bin ich doof oder nicht weil
es jetzt gemacht habe das war's von
heute bis zum nächsten mal und